awesome all at this altitude I can run
flat out for a half-mile before my hands
start shaking and oil suppose I'm a type
of medic organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton so this episode is
brought to you by soothe dot-com the
world's largest on-demand massage
service what and let me tell you I have
a high bar for this stuff I have body
work done at least once a week because I
broken my body I have 30-plus fractures
and 100-plus MRIs I need body work so I
have a very very very high bar for that
sooth which I've tested I tested my
assistance tested my employees tested
delivers a hand-selected licensed and
experienced massage therapist to you in
the comfort of your own home Hotel our
office in as little as an hour I've
tested them in San Francisco I've tested
them in Austin have tested them all over
the place and I have to say I was really
really amazed at the quality of
therapists and I do not accept
mediocrity at all in this area the
process is super simple think of it as
uber for massages right you choose the
kind of massage you want say Swedish or
sports massage deep tissue whatever then
if you want you can opt for couples
massage I imagine that's an edge case as
the tech people say but whatever you set
the length your massage so you let's say
you want 60 minutes 90 minutes two hours
and let's be real if you want a proper
massage go for ninety one hundred twenty
minutes for God's sake and you select
the gender of your therapist and then
click you're off to the races and they
bring the massage table sheets oil music
so you can unwind no matter where you
are and I have used this at Airbnb s
hotels etc soothe is in 50 cities
including most major US cities as well
as a London Sydney Melbourne Toronto and
Vancouver so number one download the app
sue
soo th e in the iOS App Store Google
Play Store and then use the code let me
try that again use the code Titans 20 TI
ta n 2-0 Titan 20 all caps to get $20
off of your first massage that's a lot
that's a very good discount so you
should use it
so again download the app soothe soo th
e and try out the code Titan 20 all caps
for $20 not % $20 off your first massage
and if you're anything like me I have
been paying and I've been enjoying so
give it a shot try out soothe and your
muscles nervous system and sleep well
thank you for it
what the [ __ ] gotta read with that it
was pretty good that's what I think okay
enjoy
bye this episode is brought to you by
WordPress my go-to platform for blogging
writing online creating websites
everything I love WordPress to bits my
site every site just about that I have
is run on WordPress and the lead
developer of WordPress Matt Mullenweg
has appeared on this podcast many times
the very first episode in particular is
amazing the second I took a ton of notes
on so you should check it out but
WordPress where do I even begin I mean
the New Yorker uses it jay-z Beyonce
they use it 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN time
whether you are looking to create a
personal blog a business site both
neither something else you'll make a
huge impact when you build your website
on wordpress.com and directly from some
friends at Google I'm not going to quote
them by name but they say that WordPress
offers the best out-of-the-box SEO the
search engine optimization imaginable so
if you're on WordPress you immediately
have a leg up on everybody else on
search engines and so forth in my
experience
I'm no
medical doctor of search engine
optimization but I will say that I used
WordPress for years and fell in love
with it to the extent that I became very
close friends with Matt and then became
an investor slash advisor to automatic
which runs wordpress.com that is how
much I believe in this and that's how a
lot of my most successful products and
investments have come about because I'm
in love with X and then I seek out X
nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
WordPress and that includes everything
from the huge sites that I mentioned to
neighborhood sites and it is super easy
to get started there's no need to worry
about security or upgrades or hosting
they offer 24/7 support and handle all
of that which allows you to focus on
creating the highest quality content you
can with the least amount of friction I
don't have to worry about downtime I
don't have to worry about getting
emergency emails if I'm on vacation or
something like that and WordPress is my
go-to solution for all of this
I trust all of my most important text on
the Internet to WordPress and they can't
buy that with a sponsorship they can't
buy that with anything I want uptime
uptime uptime and quality and that is
what I have selected after everything
that I've looked at so check it out go
to WordPress that's wor DP re SS com
wordpress.com for slash Tim seriously
15% off of your website today
that's wordpress.com phone slash Tim
okay here we go it's a late night folks
that's a boo from Aladdin and this is
confess welcome to another episode of
the Tim berry show where it is my job to
every episode deconstruct a world-class
performer of some type they could be
from chess they could be from
entertainment sports business etc in
this episode we have a very special
guest because he is one of my childhood
/ adolescent icons heroes role models
Dorian Yates Dorian Yates took the
already extremely extreme sport of
bodybuilding and took it to a new level
he is a six-time mr. Olympia and a lot
of what he did in terms of innovating
and training influenced what I later put
into say the 4-hour body in terms of
Occam's protocol and many other things
you can say hello to him on twitter at
drain underscore Yates or on the
Facebook he is facebook.com forward
slash Dorian Yates dy and he along with
I would say coach Dan Gable of Iowa who
is coming I promise you that had a huge
influence on a lot of my thinking and a
lot of my physical training in this
particular conversation we dig into all
sorts of topics that I've been dying to
ask Dorian since I was 14 or 15 years
old we talked about his relationship to
pain we talked about specific workouts
like his leg workout how does he warm up
common mistakes misconceptions about him
when's he surpassed limits what is his
self-talk when he's going for a pee our
personal record we talk about his
favorite books it goes on and on and on
including why he views freedom as not
giving a [ __ ] he is a fascinating guy to
speak with came from nothing built
himself up into a hero in his chosen
sport and has since reinvented and
redefined himself in Spain of all places
so we cover it all and I sincerely hope
you enjoy this conversation as much as I
did there are many cases when you meet
your heroes and
they have clay feet you're disappointed
but in this case I came way having much
more respect for Dorian and I already
had a lot and much more fascination with
this character is truly multifaceted so
without further ado please enjoy this
conversation with Dorian Yates Dorian
welcome to the show okay Sam thanks for
having my on I am so excited to have you
on the show and I would like to start
with thanking you on behalf of a young
lad this is probably somewhere between
17 and 20 years ago who emailed you out
of the blue because he had a sports
nutrition company and you got on the
phone with him and you're very very
gracious ultimately he couldn't make it
worth your time to become any type of
sponsored athlete or affiliated with the
company but you really took the time and
it was very memorable and that person
was me so I did not know that the
company was first brain quick and then
body quick and then body quick and it
moved around and ended up just fine
had taken me on my own journey but I
have followed you and your career from
as early as I can really remember
gathering a handful of icons in my youth
and we had Dorian Yates and then we had
Dan Gable legendary wrestling coach and
I was very much impacted in terms of how
you think and approach training to start
with and there's no there's a lot more
to that but what I was not familiar with
at the time and I'm sure a lot of people
listening have no context on is a bit of
your background and childhood could you
tell us a little bit about where you
grew up and what your childhood was like
yeah well and initially I guess it was
quite idyllic because I was brought up
on a little what we call in England a
smallholding so it's kind of like a very
small farm and we had horses there and
dogs and chickens and all kind of
animals and stuff like that so that was
pretty cool
but everything changed when I was 13 and
my father died from a heart attack and
then my mom was going to get remarried
and moved to Birmingham which is second
biggest city in UK so I went from a
rural you know kind of a more rural
existence to you know my father dying
and move into the city and when I was 16
I left home my mum wanted to go living
back in the you know back in the
countryside and so on and I decided to
stay on in the city so I was 16 years
old no qualifications from school and
nowhere to live really I was living a
friend's place and stuff like that and
when I was 18 I got arrested and was
really just a stupid thing me and some
friends were drunk and in the wrong
place at the wrong time but anyway I got
sent to a detention centre when I was 18
which is like a youth jail facility I
guess the idea is to put the you know
young guys again in trouble put them in
there for a short period of time and
it's very kind of military that
discipline in marching everywhere do a
lot of sports and you like try to learn
some kind of skill or you know job or
something like that while you even in
any case that had weights in there which
I've done a little bit of previously and
you know saw the magazines and
everything and I think I've trained for
about six months when I was at school I
was doing karate first and then started
doing with a weight training so I had an
interest in a little background in there
and in the facility that had weights in
there and I got you know you had to do
this I remember the first one of the
first times were in there in the sports
or you know they give us this like
circuit training to do you know squats
[Applause]
pull-ups push-ups all kind of like in a
circuit and I took around the circuit
three times and do so many reps and you
know when you're finished sit down so
every one man
that thing three times and sat down the
prison officer was like you know what I
was making fun or something he's like I
gotta go you got to go around three
times over did go around three times you
know and he didn't believe me so made me
do it again so I was stronger than was a
few hundred eyes in there was stronger
than most of them and had you know the
best physique and I was good with the
weights and I you know at that point I
think I found something that was you
know stop screwing around or something
here you can be you could do something
with I think at that point was was as
far as I went enough when you left home
at 16 or separated from a separate path
from your mother what was that
conversation like I mean was there
particular dinner did she see it coming
was at the total surprise
no all the story is my mother moved to
Birmingham after my father died to
remarry
another gentleman and then quite
tragically had a heart attack as well
with him it was in within two years so
my mum had no reason than to to stay in
the city I guess so she wanted to move
back and she discussed with me whether
I'd want to do that or not and I said I
didn't want to do that so I just decided
to go my own way mhm and so I was
watching a documentary about you
recently which was at least co-produced
by the person who introduced us well
introduced us to say the the second time
17 years later Brian Rose of London real
and there is the observation that there
very few picks it's hard to find a
picture of you smiling before 1997 know
something I you know I didn't really
realize myself I guess but I think it
was a case of me being so
tunnel-visioned in pursuit of while I
was doing it's almost like it's not that
I wanted to do it I had to do it you
know and
it wasn't much time for fun you know
really you know people used to say to me
why why don't you smile on stage it was
previous to me most of the girls would
you know that would pose on stage and
smile and try to look happy and I just
couldn't fake it I mean by the time I
got to a contest you totally exhausted
and tired and you're dehydrated and your
body fat slow and you've been on a diet
for three months and for me it was a
competition it was a war I was going to
win so was not really in a you know
smiling kind of mood so I think I
brought it a new whole new kind of
persona to the sport that wasn't there
before not purposely but just by being
myself I think but just being genuine
why did you or how did you get the
nickname the shadow I got the nickname
of shadow from a good friend of mine
probably the most respected writer in
bodybuilding his name's Peter McGough
and it's a funny story because Peter
McGough was a reporter for small British
magazine when I did my first competition
and eventually Peter become the editor
of flex magazine which was Joe weeders
you know famous bodybuilding magazine in
the States anyway Peter was the one that
came up with that nickname because I was
kind of the opposite to what
bodybuilders general were at that time
you know quite extrovert and wanted to
bring attention to themselves and I was
opposite and my policy was to go to a
contest like my first contest and turned
up and people you know never heard of me
and they were quite shocked at how good
my development was and then I would you
know disappear and keep covered up and
keep in my GM and even though there's no
internet no social media or anything
like that so the only exposure to get
through that was through the magazines
and so I'd go to a contest win the
contest and disappear and just go back
to my gym and concentrate on my training
so more summer elusive I guess compared
to the other characters in the sport so
that's where the name the shadow
and what was what was the gym like where
you built your physique when you would
vanish and go back across the pond to
the UK could you describe the gym where
you were building your physique yeah the
gym was I was right in the centre city
centre of Birmingham and the building is
probably one of the oldest buildings in
the center you know very few hundred
years old I guess and and it was in the
basement of this old building where the
gym was and I think it was something
like including the changing room and
everything is less than 2,000 square
feet so very small you go down some
narrow stairs into this basement so it's
very much like a dungeon it reminds me
of some of the dungeons I've seen an old
castle I mean they always in the back
you know you go down there's no windows
down there so you kind of get down there
you're totally isolated and I remember
people used to be nervous to come
through the door and go down the stairs
because you know it's like this steps
into descending into hell or something
you don't know what's down there and it
can hear all these weights clanking and
smell you know smell of a sweat and hear
people grunting and groaning so people
have actually kind of real scared to go
down what what is a good thing wasn't a
commercial venture at that point us
actually it was my gym and I opened in
the 80s when gyms were far and few
between least in the UK so we're doing a
good business but in the 90s it really
became my base for training and we
didn't care too much whether you know
trying to get the members in and so on
so it's kind of like if you like it you
can come down trainer and pay your fees
that you're done we don't really care
you know so it's not hey well it was not
a commercial venture at all it's a
workshop I it it comes to mind that a
lot of people listening are perhaps not
familiar with bodybuilding or have done
some training don't know much about your
career when you are at say your
your peak in terms of training whenever
you felt like it was most dialed in what
did your workout split look like over
the span of a week or two weeks is there
it perhaps an example of what that might
have looked like yeah I mean it was kind
of evolving over the time but what I
settled down to when I was professional
and especially if you're a professional
bodybuilder then this is a profession so
you can dedicate all your time to doing
this but even having said that there's a
limit on which you can train if you want
to be productive so I'd split my body
into four different workouts it would be
chest and biceps one workout legs would
be a separate workout and I would
include hamstrings and calf's in there I
really had pretty strong cast from from
the time I started so there weren't a
priority so other people might want to
do things differently you know you've
got a design everything tailored to the
individual and so that was that was two
workouts back to back then and take a
day off and then have a back workout and
the next day after that we shoulders and
triceps and another day off so that's a
six-day cycle and that was flexible as
well depending on how I felt so very
often after a leg day it was so
exhausting and so depleting not just on
the legs but on the whole you know your
whole system and nervous system and so
on so very often will be a two-day break
after that so that meant that I was
getting around to training everything
just once a week or once every six days
seven days ended on how I was feeling
so I've seen footage of people vomiting
after your leg workouts and you
mentioned people would be intimidated or
afraid when they went down into the
dungeon and it seems like that was
particularly common with those people
you invited to do leg day with you what
what did your leg day what might a
worked a leg day workout look like well
you know if you work if you write it
down on a piece of paper
it doesn't mean much it doesn't look
like much is nothing special so let's
let's see how it would look on a piece
of paper would be three sets of leg
extensions three sets of leg press and
two sets of squats on a hack squat
machine or a smith machine earlier in my
career did do free squats by stop doing
them as a father when a productive and
injury risk was was too great for me
so that would be quads and after that
would be two sets of leg curls two sets
of stiff legged deadlifts two sets of
standing calf raises and two sets of
seated calf raises so hey that looks
like a breeze right now it's not much
written down a piece of paper but the
point is is what you put into it it's
the intensity that you put into those
sets and even let me take you through
the first exercise leg extensions the
first set would be quite light and quite
easy so the goal there is to get in
touch with the muscle you know feel the
muscle contract and stretch and get the
blood in there so it's warming up the
second set would be more difficult but
not to absolute maximum and then the
third set is the one that I call the
working set or the one that really
really counts because the other two
they're within your capacity so they're
not going to do anything quite frankly
apart from warming you are because your
body has no reason to change if it's
working within its capacity what you
know why would it and you have to
overload it have to give it something
that it's not used to that that's going
to be a shock basically a muscle growth
is an ADD plantation it's your stress so
you've got to give your muscles more
stress than they're accustomed to
otherwise they won't change quite
basically that's it so that last set you
could just got to put everything into it
and it's not about throwing weights
around and screaming and shouting it's
about concentrating is about doing the
movement correctly is about moving the
weights slowly and under control even
when it gets absolutely torturously hard
and impossible to do those
threats at the end that's where we have
a trained environment to come and help
you squeeze out of those last couple of
reps and when you do go to what's true
muscular failure with a large muscle
group like a legs and glutes and so on I
mean it's absolutely exhausting because
you use so much oxygen so after that set
you'll you know you'll be breathing like
a train probably start to feel very
nauseous and so on so if you're not you
know can I use that kind of work then
very often people do vomit yeah it's not
my goal
is that my goal particularly to get them
to do that but you know sometimes is a
bit of a shot and but Pete knows people
don't train with me all the time so I'm
trying to like part of my job as I see
it as a trainer is to take them to show
them where they can go
so which I'm very good at because I can
observe people and I know exactly what
they can do where their limit is and
they don't know that yet
so it's like me taking them by the hand
and like take them out there and like
you know this is where you got to be in
the third set is to true-true muscular
failure through muscular failure and
then in my opinion you don't need to do
another set on that particular exercise
and so we move on to another exercise
which for argument state could could be
laborious and now we're involving the
gluts and maybe a little bit around the
lower back that we did on the leg
extensions so we're going to warm up
again one or two sets depends on what
you need and again then absolute fail a
going to have one guy either side of the
leg press machine to make sure you know
you're safe while you go to absolute
failure and perhaps they're going to
help you a little bit on the last last
two reps and so it's all about intensity
probably get through this workout around
40 45 minutes so very intense to just
stress the muscles give them something
that I used to and then the rest of your
job as a bodybuilder is really
recovering from their stress and
repairing your body you know you've got
a review we've got a recover
asked and then you can repair and
hopefully overcompensate a little bit
and if we were looking at a leg
extension exercise and hypothetically
let's say you're you're working set
weight is a hundred pounds yeah how what
is the repetition range or the time that
attention range that is your target for
failure if you have one and then if a
hundred pounds is your working set what
might first and second set use well
actually we've got this all documented
because now I'm have a my certification
program dya chai tea so donate size and
high-intensity training so we've got
this all documented and the guideline
would be if your maximum set so Tim you
you you know you reckon you can do a
hundred pounds on the leg extension for
10 reps that that'll be a max so we'd
probably start with half of that like
fifty percent for your first set nice
alight second set probably 70 percent so
70 pounds in this case and and then you
know ready to rock and roll and 100
pounds and you thought you could do 10
but we all probably get like thirteen or
fourteen ality but we'll get you beyond
what you thought and then that's the
lesson in itself to say hey you know you
can go a little bit more and these are
the ones account the last one or two
reps the universe that's the magic but
that's where the magic happens you know
definitely and if you can do a hundred
pounds on a leg extension for 10 reps
last week if you did that last week you
can do that for next the rest of your
life in and nothing's going to happen
that I'll guarantee you and I'll see it
happen all the time people will get some
progress first year maybe 18 months but
then the body becomes accustomed become
smart and I want to keep that thing to
the stress so it just you know you got
you've got to really push it to get
results beyond that point and I won't
spend this entire time in the weeds but
I'm so curious just to whet people's
appetite for the documentation that you
mentioned between the safe first light
set the sec
heavier set and the third work set how
much rest do you take between the sets
or how do you know when you're ready to
go I don't like to work with too much
with you know a stopwatch I kind of
observe somebody if I'm training them or
I teach them to observe themselves and
basically the guideline is you rest in
between the sets as long as as long as
you need so that you will be able to do
the following set to muscular failure so
let's say we did you know we did a set
of leg pressing you're breathing like a
steam train and we jump on and try and
do another set after 30 seconds you're
going to fail due to cardiovascular
failure rather than real muscular
failure on the other hand if we rest you
know way too long between the sets we're
going to lose use lose some of the
intensity of the workout so it's kind of
a balancing thing got to rest long
enough so your breathing is somewhat
normal so that you are not going to run
out of gas on your next set and so it
would depend on the size of the muscle
groups being trained if you're doing a
squat leg press deadlift exercises like
that multi-joint exercises that are
using the largest muscles in your body
is going to be a huge oxygen that if you
go to failure so you're going to need to
rest longer between those sets as
opposed to hey we just done a bicep curl
you know so I think if it's really heavy
leg training it could be three or four
minutes between sets easily whereas you
know bicycle deltoid raise you could be
a minute or less got it and what there's
one back up it's not limited to back but
one exercise I would love to talk about
and that's the bent row so I remember
way back in the early 90s I saw a lot of
photographs of you performing vent rose
with a palms up supinated grip and so
for people listening who may not
be able to easily distinguish I had a
lot of trouble remembering supinated and
pronated so if you want to have drink
soup out of your hand then you have to
turn it up so the point about biceps and
I said ah and do you could you describe
how you performed the bent row it
doesn't have to be that variation but
yeah and or how you teach people to do
it like what is the right way to do a
bent row in your mind well you know
first of all I should say I'm a you know
I'm very studious I like to study things
I studied nutrition right from you know
from day one I bought books on nutrition
and studied nutrition I bought you know
I must have had every book that's been
published every magazine from the early
eighties until the day I retired so I've
read everybody else's training articles
and books and everything so gained a lot
of information from here and there and
the bent-over row I came up with that
position lifting my body up above
parallel the old traditional way to do
bent over rows was with the body
parallel to the floor fairly wide grip
and pulling the bar into the chest which
is fine if you want to work the upper
back rhomboids and lower trapezius and
so on but the area that I saw that was
lacking and most bodybuilders was the
middle to low lats and when that's fully
developed honest there can you get that
Christmas tree separation it looks
really dramatic you know and just a
pause there for people who don't know
what that might mean I was going to
bring this up later but just googled
Dorian Yates Christmas tree back to see
what this looks like well you get the
Christmas tree kind of shape the
separation between whether that's
attached and the spinal erectors so
obviously you got to be in very lean
condition literally no body fat there so
you can see all the separation fine
separation of those muscles so what I
was trying to do was to thicken my mid
and lower lat naturally my what my lats
are very wide always had a good back but
I got beaten twice in
professional bodybuilding the first was
my debut in the professional ranks and I
was beaten by a guy called Mohammed
Benna Caesar and my first show which was
called mites of Champions in New York
1990 if anyone wants to go and look
Mohammed be been Azusa was an incredible
bodybuilder very short I think was only
like five four or something like that
but anyway he beat me and his back was
like 3d thickness you know and mine
wasn't quite there yet so I got inspired
by that and start working on my lower
Lance mid back and I realized with the
reverse grip I could really kind of pull
the elbows further back at the top and
squeeze and really contract that the
lower Lance so that's why I started
working with the reverse grip and
between Mohammed Bouazizi who beat me on
the first contest and Lee Haney who beat
me in my first mr. Olympia where I got
second Lee Haney again was had a super
like three dimensional thickness on the
lower Lance it wasn't quite as lean with
the separation but he had very
impressive thickness so those two guys
pushed me to like you know further
concentrate in the area and thicken up
and actually I became really well known
for that and then probably more than
those so guys I would I mean certainly
based on my obsessive reading of all the
magazines at the time I think that's
that's certainly true and when you're
performing an exercise like that form of
row do you think much about tempo in
terms of the speed of lifting are there
any pauses how do you think about that
absolutely um well first of all you need
to understand the the function of the
muscle and exercise and how that's
performing the function you need to kind
of get your head inside the muscle so
you feel it stretch you feel it contract
you almost become like part of the
fibers and I often say bodybuilding is
really the opposite of weightlifting or
powerlifting where their job is to get
the weight from point A to point B
however
you know the easiest of best way to do
that is and so they use momentum these
mechanics use as many muscle groups to
lift the weight whereas the bodybuilder
is using the weight as a tool so to
speak in order to put maximum stress on
the particular muscle group they're
trying to isolate and work so it's very
important to move the weight in a
controlled manner and not to create any
kind of Swing or momentum to move the
weights and the most important thing
that people don't realize is that you
have different phases of the rep you
have the positive which is the lifting
which everybody kind of concentrates on
and then you've got the lowering of the
weight or the negative phase which
people kind of just tend to rush through
but I think a lot of the muscle damages
occurs on the negative father rep so you
know we could argue which one is more
important the positive and negative I
say I don't know so let's do both of
them to the absolute maximum you know
and and you always stronger in the
negative phase of an exercise so unless
you're slowing down the negative unless
you're consciously slowing down the
negative part of the movement you're
never going to fully tax that part
because you might fail on the lifting
and I'll say you're doing bench press
and you're pushing it up right and you
can't push any more in a positive way in
our way of pushing the weight on but if
somebody lifted the way to the top - you
could probably lower two or three more
because the negative phase of the muscle
is not exhausted so in order to get
somewhere near exhaustion of a negative
phase you need to slow that down so I
tell people you need to do the positive
quite explosively but not swinging and
then consciously slow down a negative
although I don't like to you know count
seconds and so on how did you how did
you connect with Mike mentor and who is
Mike for people who don't know well as I
said I did a lot of studying and I think
I'm quite a logical thinker and my
mentor was mr. universe professional
bodybuilder
top composer and mr. Olympia and the mic
was around and in the magazines when I
started reading magazines and he was had
a kind of unique training system I guess
called heavy duty and this was short
relatively compared to how the other
guys were training anyway
short intense workouts and Mike would be
the first one to say that he got pretty
much all these principles from a guy
called Arthur Jones who made a line of
exercise machines called Nautilus
machines way back in the 70s and Arthur
Jones was I guess a pretty brilliant guy
and he was a self-made billionaire with
no financial interest in the
bodybuilding world really
it just made these nauseous machines
because he felt they're the best way to
build muscle it was something that's
very interested in he used to have the
Arnold Schwarzenegger and my mentor of
kcb ate all these guys go out to his
place in Florida to train anyway Arthur
was the first guy to say you know what's
the science behind muscle growth and to
point out that the intensity is really
the key factor intensity and recovery
and so on so all the the principles
heavy high intensity training weight
training come originally from Arthur
Jones got refined by men sir maintenance
or was somebody that I admired very much
and you know so I guess I took those
methods maybe refine them more over the
years but the guy that deserves a credit
for originally pointing out a lot of
facts as the first guy to talk about
genetics you know about previous to that
you know had been sold a story that you
know everybody could be mr. universe and
mr. Lampe if you train like Arnold meat
like Arnold and so on
Arthur Jones as a first guy to point out
scientifically that's you know it's not
possible and people have different
genetic abilities to to build muscle
just like they had for running and
jumping
singing or whatever also doesn't know
right yeah it's it's the the raw
materials that you begin with whether
it's you have better myostatin
inhibition than someone else or fill in
the blank there there's so many
variables known and unknown and for
people who have only now heard the name
Arthur Jones for the first time I highly
recommend he's a very colorful character
and a good writer also checking out some
of his earlier his bulletins that he
would put out and some of his writing he
had a crocodile farm he was very very
odd and eccentric but there's Marx
Africa yeah he had yeah he had gorillas
as well once I mean there's a picture of
one of the gorillas in the Nautilus full
of a machine I think they had to to put
the girl on some heavy sedatives and
symptoms of fishing and also school of
the Machine but that's a pretty famous
scripture yeah he's a colorful guy and
obviously a very very smart guy and a
thinker and you know I read all his
stuff a read my menses stuff and then
that was kind of coupled with my own
observations in the gym that if I did
more than a certain amount or four
trains more often my progress would just
come to a halt then I would you know get
run down get tired take a week off and
guess what would happen after a week off
from a gym and go back and boom I was
stronger why was that it was because my
body was exhausted and depleted there
wasn't recovered I took a week off and
it recovered and rebuilt itself and I
was stronger so there was a lesson there
you got a train you got to put stress on
the muscles you got to break them down
and then you must let your body recover
and you know that takes time and it
takes a good nutrition is wrong when you
observe people who are attempting or
hear from people who are attempting some
form of high-intensity training or some
type of rationale limited volume to
failure training what are the most
common mistakes
that you see or the most some of the
most common misconceptions either I
think the most common misconceptions is
that you got to use a ton of weight I
you know if you look at my training
videos of blood and guts that were
filmed yes I'm using what can be
considered very heavy weights in there
but I'm using them in the correct way so
if I wanted to lift more weights in
those particular exercises I'd probably
put it down but I would have to do in a
form that was not you know was not put
in the maximum the muscles that I'm
trying to Train so the first
misconception is that you're going to be
throwing around tons of weight you're
going to be using a weight as at all I
think that's the main mistake that
people make and also because they've
read about beyond failure training
techniques so four people are not
familiar if you're lifting a weight and
gets to a point where you you're stuck
you can't complete the rather than as
failure you can go beyond that point if
you've got a training partner there to
slightly assist you just to get one two
or more reps right at the end of the set
that's the correct way to do force reps
but people get carried away with it and
then the gym they've got too much weight
on there and they're doing like one rep
correctly and then the trainer partners
help them on the second and third rep
and that's you know that's not going to
get you anywhere far from injured so I'd
love to talk a little bit about the
mental and
self-talk said in 1990 I want to talk
about that loss but could you place for
us in 1990 where were you living what
were you doing when you were not on
stage competing okay in 1990 I was
living with my first wife or I don't
think we were married at that time we
were living together with my son and
we're living in a two-bedroom
council estate maisonette so people in
states wouldn't know what a counseled
the state is I guess it's like what you
call it in the States but government
housing in an affordable housing order
the government house and whatever it is
not not the best place to live
probably you know he started noisy
neighbors always stuff like this
problems going on so I was living there
I was making a living from the gym which
I had had for about three years at that
point and there were not a lot of gyms
around so that you know let's make an OK
living from the gym and supporting my
wife and child and you know the expenses
Valley incurred and by the billing with
a diet and supplements and all that kind
of stuff so that's where I was that and
I was the best you know I won nineteen
ninety-eight had won the British
championship heavyweight and overall and
that qualified me to be a professional
and I chose the show and I have the
champions as it was called at a time
which was kind of a very prestigious
show to like try and do a debut and
quite well-respected and if you go in
the top five of that show you could go
on to compete in the mr. Olympia so it's
quite an attractive show to do and so at
this point you know I've been doing this
thin for five years now competing and
training and really absolutely putting
everything into it and you know
sacrifice social life sacrifice friends
time and the family and you know if you
got a family then that means they're
sacrificing as well so I observed a lot
of people around me a lot of people
following this bodybuilding dream you
know and they weren't getting anywhere
and they weren't going to get anywhere
because they didn't have what it took
but you know they were still making all
these sacrifices and you know damaging
relationships and business and money and
lots of things you know that
you're totally focused on this thing so
I said I want to be one of those guys
and I'll observe the way things work if
you're going to be a top professional
and you're going to make it in the sport
of what everyone as a professional then
you pretty much going to make a mark
from you know from your first contest
you don't you don't go into a pro
contest and get 15th place and then next
year when mr. Olympia because it doesn't
work like that so if you've got what it
takes
it's going to be apparent you have all
of these sacrifices that you're making
you are living in a place with its own
problems or challenges certainly when
you found out that you did not win and
after that maybe it's the night after or
the day after what was your self-talk
like or are you saying yourself if you
remember oh I'll tell you what the
self-talk was before I got there because
that's a pretty relevant so I saw
everything that's going on around me and
I said right I'm going to do this I'm
going to take 18 months off after my
British championship win I'm going to
take 18 months off I'm going to give
100% focus to this contest absolutely
everything I've got and if I don't place
in the top five of this contest
then I won't compete again you know
because I'm got retakes basically so
I'll concentrate on the gym maybe open
another team something like that but as
for you know being a competitive
professional bodybuilder that would be
the end for me but I'm placing the top
five so I put myself on a bit of
pressure and so in the end I got second
place but I mean it was a great lineup
and some people in there like Robbie
Robinson
I mean this guy was a hero of mine when
I started you know and and before I went
to America I was pretty much told by
everybody that I didn't have much of a
chance because I didn't have any name
recognition
I wasn't known by any of the judges or
the promoters had no publicity and
magazines
and plus your English and they're going
to save it in America athletes and you
know all this negative stuff which I
didn't really listen to I just though if
I'm good enough I'm good enough that's
it so I made a huge impact to the show
the crowd is a very vocal and that was
their favorite and from that showing I
got invited to to California to go to
Gold's Gym and do a photo shoot for the
wheeler magazines and all this stuff so
although I didn't win the contest and
I've probably got more out of it and the
guy that did win it wait because because
I was brand new and such a different
look and soner and everything in the
crowd was going crazy
so I was not disappointed at all in
getting second it was like a vindication
for me I was like wow I am good enough
then because I got a second and his
first pro contest with no publicity no
nothing and it was a close second as
well and I paid a lot of really good
season bodybuilders and professionals so
maybe I do have what it takes
what would you say from so we're looking
in 1990 was that a similar experience to
your first mr. Olympia competition was
the self-talk before and after the same
or did it change at all it was different
because at this point my confidence was
built in because following here in 91
when I did my first mr. Olympia earlier
in the year to qualify for the mr.
Olympia I did this same contest again
Night of Champions and this time won it
and you know was improved from the
previous year Zeke was better I was
feeling more confident more comfortable
with being on stage and doing that part
of it so the one hurdle really was that
Lee Haney was mr. Olympia when I started
training and you know so he's the guy
that I've been looking up to all these
years you know as mr. Lincoln and now I
realize I've got to change my mindset
because this is no longer
you know the here of the guy I got to go
there and try and beat this guy so if I
have this you know this approach to it
while it's Lee Haney is mr. Limpy and
wrong you know of course great respect
what I had to go as a competitor so I
had to say what you know now that I as a
competitor and you know what is a man
who's got two arms two legs he lifts
weights and I think maybe I can beat him
because nobody lifts weight harder than
me so maybe you know gives me a lot of
confidence going into it so it didn't
happen but once again it was a very
close second and it's the first time
they'd only got second on their debut
oven at mr. Olympia shows a couple of
first there and I was happy with the
placing you know some people are
conscious said I should have won and
what-have-you but I think at the time it
was a fair result so the the next
question is going to be about 92 to 97
and obviously feel free to take this off
track somewhere else but I've always in
watching videos of you watching looking
at photographs of you training wondered
about your relationship to pain so let's
say during that 92 to 97 how did you
think about pain or relate to it and I
don't know if that's a good question or
not but I've always wanted to ask it I
don't know I think you've become
accustomed to pain you know and make
friends with it and I even look for it I
mean I I was gonna I was talking to a
song to somebody and I was explaining
look my legs were sore like can't sit
down on toilets or for
three or four days of every week of my
life for like more than 10 years yeah
yeah so if I was not hobbling around for
a few days of every week in pain
uncomfortable to sit down uncomfortable
to sleep hours and happy I wasn't doing
my job properly so you know with me it
almost became like I had no fear and it
became it made me maybe a little
reckless at times and perhaps that's why
I got injured going really pro con
because I was doing stuff before
concepts of probably wasn't necessary I
realize now and you know your your
intake of nutrients is less you're more
dehydrated you're tired so the injury
risk gets greater going for conscious
and the to serious injuries I had to
have been in the last six weeks for
contest so but in our literally is to go
in and take the weights and you know you
you I felt I was indestructible you
often do when you're young you know yeah
so I I had a certainly not to that
extreme necessarily but well let me just
ask I mean how much how much weight in
terms of water and dehydration would you
lose in the last 24 to 36 hours or 48
hours prior to a competition um probably
not a lot hopefully I mean some people
used to do extreme things but because I
was very calculated I'll probably be
within within five or six pounds of my
conscious weight from like a couple of
weeks out that's antastic so yeah and
then the last week I would just
manipulate carbohydrates and water and
so on to try and get a little dryer
between skin and so on and so you get
the separation the muscles coming out
but I probably lose a couple of pounds
less two days it wasn't very drastic but
it you know is the end of usually I
think 12 weeks to specifically dial in
for a contest
I was when I had a number of my most
serious injuries and needed
reconstructive shoulder surgery and have
a number of different tendon and
ligament issues it was always while I
was dehydrating for making way for
competitive wrestling that I wrestled
for more than a decade and I almost all
of the major injuries and chronic
injuries and issues that I have now I
can trace back to a period of extreme
dehydration well that could have been
the case with me on earth there was
extreme dehydration or combination of
slight dehydration extremely low body
fat tiredness rate you know it could be
combination of all those factors but
dehydration absolutely is going to
increase your risk what you come back
and hopefully I'm not beating a dead
horse here but I think it's really
valuable for people to hear and I'm
fascinated by it the how you utilize
self-talk because in this conversation
with you in conversations that I've
heard of yours you seem very good at
speaking to yourself well giving
yourself instructions and feedback well
and I what brought this to mind was
watching footage of you looking at old
training journals and I in the journal
not only did you have the specifics of a
given workout but you
there is one line and as I'm not going
to be getting this perfectly right but
it's something like I am ashamed of this
workout from from this point on it's all
guns blazing or something yes stop
screwing around and uh could you could
you describe how you used that type of
written feedback and some insistent
notes and motivation and what I would do
as well as like set goals and when I
whenever I advise people I tell them
this it's just instead of saying
something to get a fan get a piece of
paper and write it down
it just makes it a hundred times more
powerful you know I'm going to do this I
want to lose this amount of weight I'm
going to do this and I'm going to do you
know but you got to be realistic I'm
going to do this in four weeks I'm going
to lose I don't know I'm going to lose
four pounds in four weeks and write it
down
and then how are you going to do that
write it down you know all everything I
wrote everything down so I had a plan
and I'd even rehearse it's funny it's
almost like instinctively I think some
of it is instinct and some of it was
studying the whole sports psychology I
pretty much got it down very quickly you
know I didn't need anyone to coach me on
it I kind of found out myself and plus
you know reading all the stuff ideas and
other people I think might münster used
to advocate keeping the training diary
so I probably picked that up from there
and even before going to work out I
would sit down at the training diary and
I'd look at what I did last week so this
is what I did last week these old
exercises all the sets these all the
reps okay so this is what I want to do
today I want to do I did 250 pounds for
six reps last week only there's seven or
eight this week I saw seven or eight on
that bench press and when I get down on
that bench press the weights going to
feel like this and I'm going to bring it
down it's going to feel like this and
what are they wearing this shirt it's
like literally used to visualize the
whole workout before I even went to the
gym so I know exactly what I was doing
in what order and and everything and
that was just dialed in so I wouldn't
even talk to anybody want to went to the
gym you know just do my workout so you
could have a plan you know if you just
wonder in the gym and thing on what
should i do today you're not going to
get anywhere so when you walk in with a
plan and let's say you get to a
particular exercise where your work set
is going to be a new PR for you a new
personal record yeah what is going on in
your head between either like when you
walk in the gym or in the minutes prior
to that that set
is just really confirming what you're
going to do and you know why you're
doing it you've got either type of
motivation and you're not going to put
yourself through a pain and discomfort
this is some kind of motivation so
what's your motivation for doing this
and how bad you want it and for me it
was like I thought that really you know
that's that's how I felt anyway life or
death I got to do this I've got to
change my life and this is what I've got
to do and this is the road I'm going to
take and nothing's going to stop me but
you know that was my personal motivation
you got everyone's got to find their own
but you're only going to push as hard as
you're your motivation personal so let's
let's dig into that a little bit because
I so after one of the mr. Olympius maybe
multiple us when you're going to start
training again and then he would say
very straight face next week and instead
of Baga boggled people's minds because
they were like why don't you take a few
months off you're like why don't you
take a few months off of sex in other
words if you enjoy it why I like trying
him so I'm going to take it you know
maybe it maybe it would have been good
sometimes like a couple of weeks off
probably give my joints to rest and so
on but I was a man with a mission and
you know it's hard to like control that
fire sometimes when you see life or
death what was feeding that fire was
there anything else that was was driving
you or was it just a fire I mean who
knows deep psychological risks perhaps
who knows I'm sure that because I didn't
have an easy childhood and and you know
particularly close and loving family and
all these kind of things other people
might have and I think that are really
comfortable upbringing like that I
probably wouldn't be the driven person I
was in it so I'm sure there's something
there in that in wanting to achieve or
want to be recognized or something but
in any case it in some ways it felt like
I already
already knew that I was going to do this
or had to do this I don't know if that
that's easy to understand but it's yeah
it's almost like I have to I knew I was
going to do this
what are certain beliefs that you had
then that you think were unhelpful now
if you look back at your competitive
career or the period of time after that
after you're sidelined taken out by
injuries what what are what are beliefs
that you have that we're unhelpful or
things that you've really changed your
mind about a lot and in the last say a
decade or two or since competing I think
what I struggled with and I think this
is very common with athletes that I had
tunnel vision is like who are you you
know
who I you know that that goal has been
is not there it's been taken away other
one who other we want to put it with me
was injury so all throughout my career
was very controlled and uncontrolled
everything can when I competed and all
this kind of stuff
and this I didn't have control of
because it was like you're injured and
you can't compete in the morning and
that's it so I didn't have control over
that
this was bicep and tricep yeah was bicep
was the original injury which brought
look in see photographs of it's
basically here you tips your fingers to
your arm that is just black on one over
that was six weeks before the contest in
1994 and game you know six weeks out
maybe baby little dehydrated tires body
fat slow and I was training too heavy
for that phase of my training was doing
440 pounds bent over rows and yeah the
bicep popped so I wasn't indestructible
you know and what did you find helpful
or unhelpful for finding peace with
yourself after losing that singular goal
I think it takes time you know it takes
time because you've been doing this one
thing for so long and you know it's kind
of like that's all you know so it takes
some time to readjust and rebalance and
come to the realization of like okay
that's over but you know there's you can
do anything you want you know anything
you want with and you have more time now
you have more freedom to pursue things
and interests and that it wouldn't be
possible to foreclose on such a strict
regime so in the end I came to
appreciate that but it did definitely
take time you've undergone a
transformation that I think many people
would say or certainly the people who've
had
close exposure to you among other things
you know now practice yoga now you
instead of wearing only black and gray
shirts you wear white and colored shirts
which oddly enough is something that
I've started to take in the last two
years and you've changed locations
you've you've made a lot of changes to
your life in the in the last say five
years around are there any particular
experiences or teachers who have helped
you to undergo that transformation
because you seem like a far happier
human being or at peace human being now
then certainly in anything that I've
seen of you during competition or
shortly thereafter yeah I think it's a
case of constantly adjusting and I know
at some point I thought well I'm just
kind of you know doing the same things
maybe they need some more variety so I
just I started doing some different
things and I was looking at my brother
you know I've got quite a few injuries
sort of a bicep and tricep and the
supraspinatus torn on the left side so
me pursuing what I was doing before you
know trying to push away from the gym
we're starting to be kind of in some
ways could be detrimental and lead to
more injuries so I don't know I kind of
had a message and certainly that I need
to do something different and I wasn't
sure if he was over or Tai Chi or
something along those lines but I
started doing yoga and I found out
mazing for the physical side a lot more
mobility I didn't realize because I
always did some stretching when I was
training so quads and hamstrings and you
know basic stretches it was pretty good
on four especially a bodybuilder I guess
but a lot of the mobility and twisting
things like that was quite limited I
remember I was talking to a chiropractor
friend of mine who's like you know
people didn't used to get back problems
you know under the hundred years ago
because he used to sit so much around
the campfire in that squat position and
you know they'd sit like that for hours
and if you can sit like that and you're
comfortable you probably won't have any
back problems well that's interesting
let me sit in the squat and it was very
kind of uncomfortable and tighten didn't
feel right you know so yeah well so I
was led to do the yoga and I enjoyed the
physical side of it the mobility for
stretching and also the kind of
spiritual side as well and I do
meditation as well as yoga and but I
still like to push physically I do
cycling over here in spannabis and good
steep hills so I do cycling up the hills
and you know people can hear me shouting
and screaming and self going up the
hills there so I still like to push
myself I do some functional training in
the gym with ropes and pushing sleds and
stuff like that sighs you know I still
love to challenge myself I'm going to do
it you know and then still go pretty
hard and I'm very interested now just
keeping cardiovascular fitness ability
flexibility all the things that relevant
to me as I'm getting older you know this
vehicle that we have that we live in
this machine the body is the only thing
you've got to function in this you know
in this reality so it is not working
very well yeah you're not going to have
such a fun time so really that's you
know my trainings all geared to that now
to keep an efficient as same as a diet
and you know I honestly feel great
tremendous 55 the next month and I feel
great I fell better than when I was 35
well happy your early birthday number
one and number two do you remember what
your first yoga class was like or do you
have any notable yoga early yoga
experiences that you could describe yeah
funny stories so I got this thing you
know I wanted to do yoga um but I didn't
want to just go through yoga class or
I said you know what if I concentrate on
this and I think about it enough the
person will come along kind of thing so
you know I put it out there one of the
over teach on it and ask around and
through a friend of mine he said yeah I
know somebody and she's good and think
you like her and so me and gal we went
along and the first class with this lady
we did and I thought this yoga stuff
anything and it looks like a piece of
cake I'd say just stand there and do
this and some of the stuff I'm not going
out to do some physics too big but you
know it should be alright I didn't
realize how difficult some of the poses
are and how long you hold them and you
know your body's not used to that it's
not accustomed to that if you're used to
just powerful
you know powerful stuff is it's a
different kind so I was holding a pose
and like a lunging pose and my legs are
scared away and I fell on the floor you
know just like I did like a warrior pose
one of those yeah well yeah that was
exactly what it was it was like warrior
two I think and not just my legs just
buckled I couldn't stand up up on the
core and they go to teach it looked at
me and wrote you know if their eyebrows
on kind of went ah Dorian in our life
not so easy but you know you know it got
easier now that this is actually a good
point to ask that there are many
different listener and fan questions
that came in you have a lot of fans in
my audience but one of them is I think
closely related to what we're talking
about this from Nicholas Meyer knowing
what you know now what do you wish you
could change about your training program
back when you were competing if anything
like diet high intensity training versus
volume anything yeah I had this question
before so it's something of pondered on
you know right the only thing that I
think would be well two things that
would be beneficial to me if I could go
back and change them would be not
training with super intensity to the
absolute maximum the less
two months before a contest where your
calorie intake and so on restricted and
they do more cardio and you may be
dehydrated and avoid those injuries that
would be great
the other thing is I don't believe I
ever really presented the best physique
I could on stage because I generally
looks better in my opinion and I can
confirm this now by looking at photos
and you know from different perspective
maps and not quite so involved the best
physiques which are present would
probably like two or three weeks before
a contest so I always overdid it a
little bit you know Dorian Yates would
never under do anything I was always
always a tendency to overdo and that's
the thing that needed to be controlled a
little bit perhaps so those two things
are the only things that I would have
changed but would I change them
because those events led me to where I
am now so if we went back in time and
stop me from getting injured this whole
story would be different maybe I would
have completed longer and maybe that
wouldn't be good who knows
so I don't live with any regrets you
know so if I say a fact I probably
wouldn't change it so if if you were
though tasked with going back in time
and trying to convince younger Dorian to
leave a little bit of slack in the
system for the the weeks leading up the
competition to under do that a little
bit because I look back at the photos
and you're a better three weeks out what
would you have said to that young
younger Dorian well I was kind of
conscious of that the last couple of
years and I was trying not to do it but
it's still a tendency to overdo it and
you know I had a good friends when I won
in Mistral enter in 93 and it was
probably the most devastating win in the
history of the contest that it was just
outright first place and it was suppose
each size and condition that had never
been seen before so everyone was saying
to me then well you know you've got to
stop that crazy heavy training you're
doing because risk involved that I can't
do that forever and maybe just kind of
cruise now and you know hold your
position and then your money and
probably would be wise advice but it
wasn't exciting for me you know on it I
still wanted to try to push the envelope
to see how far we can go
did you ever have this is this came up a
number of times from different people
and I'm curious as well what was your
plan B if bodybuilding didn't pan out if
you if you had one well
I didn't have a plan B really I knew
that bodybuilding was going to do
something good for me and in a very
short time or won the British
Championships and got a financial backer
because of that because I didn't have
you know to finish to rub together I
didn't have a card and had anything
somebody backed me and financed me with
the gym because I was British champion
so very quickly you know I was already
earning me living that from this thing
that I love doing I've got my own gym
with doing my own equipment and I chose
and everything I'm making a nice living
so that was already happening I think
the question was whether I would be a
successful professional bodybuilder or
not if I wasn't then I probably would
open some more gyms
and who knows I was never the guy that
was going to be you know working for
somebody else or doing nine-to-five that
was never going to happen so this next
question is from Tierney Eaton and she
asks a question that also came up a
number of times and comes up a lot so
I'm sure you've heard some variation of
this what is the best way for women to
build beautiful lean muscle higher reps
with light weights or lower reps with
heavy weights I'm reading books on both
but would love to hear his opinion and
say exactly the same that would build
big muscles on a male it's absolutely no
difference in my opinion there's a lot
of hype and a lot of marketing around
women's training if women want to change
their appearance so we say change their
appearance there's only a couple of ways
you can do that you can build muscle and
or you can lose fat that's the only way
I mean you can't change your bone
structure so what makes your shape apart
from your bone structure is your muscles
and and body fat so you need high
intensity training rep range you know 8
to 12 reps and a set
going to failure and the rest is dire
you know to make sure you get sufficient
protein and eating regular small meals
and keeping a control and your calories
so it's not too much but it's enough so
a lot involved but it's you know I don't
see anything different from a lady train
to a guy training they got the same
muscles in the same places and the
response of stress in the same way I
would like to just underscore that
because I get this type of question a
lot and I don't have an opportunity to
answer it publicly or I haven't taken
the opportunity much so a few things
just because I think what you said is so
important to underscore there's a lot of
sales and marketing to women that is
very I think insulting frankly because
they use words like toning and
lengthening when you home some dogs
don't start with the toning yeah that's
my pet hate oh love what the [ __ ] does
that mean it doesn't mean anything and
then I'll tell you what it means
actually what a lady means when she says
toning she means that she's going to
look leaner and tighter
alright so her tone is going to look
muscular tone is going to look better
although it's a nonsense word I know
where you're coming from and how do you
get that look easily
well not easily but how do you get it is
you build your muscle and decrease the
body fat so the ratio of muscle to fat
is higher and then you're going to look
leaner and you're going to have that
look that your call tone and but there's
no magic exercise that can do for you no
magic diet it's it's you know consistent
weight training in the gym and good diet
and it's not you know it's not that much
of a difference in a woman's program to
a man's program it's just you know if
I'm dealing with a client I just deal
with that client on an individual basis
whether a man or woman it doesn't matter
to me I'm just you know figuring out
I'm individual right and also just for
for women who might be listening and are
concerned about getting too bulky or
whatever it might be number one I would
say you have and then I'm estimating
here but let's just say 1/10 to 120th
the free testosterone of a male and a
lot of men have difficulty adding math
so you're not going to become you know
mrs. Olympia overnight as a surprise so
you can very much notice the changes
you're not going on you're not build
muscles by mistake you know the race it
takes a lot of work to build muscles but
I know the ladies coming from maybe they
start lifting and you know first few
weeks is genes get a bit tighter or
something like that because you start to
build muscle but you as long as we
control their diet you will be losing
the body fat at the same time so you'll
get this this look that you're looking
for it's called less body fat and more
muscle yeah and that's you're looking
for and that's why you're called toned
and all these kind of nonsense terms but
that's what it is so if a lady wants to
change her body she's got to do weight
training she better do resistance
training and she's got to be conscious
about her diet and that said same as a
guy is it more difficult for a woman to
build muscle lose body fat yes probably
generally speaking less but this
assigned process even if you look back
at some of the physiques that I think
have been iconic female physics and I'm
not saying they were physique
competitors in the modern sense at all
but even Marilyn Monroe actually did
resistance training their photographs of
her doing dumbbell work absolutely we
had a big black and white poster of
Marilyn Monroe in the ladies changing
room at Temple gym down in the dungeon
say to lady stranger and it was just
like a little cupboard in the wall
really flat and I rent the room for one
lady to get changed in there and we had
a big black and white Marilyn Monroe
doing bench press with dumbbells and
you've spent
I mean you've spent a good amount of
time also just so people have context of
time around female competitors and who
are testing all these different protocol
also regimens right along side the men
so I I don't want them to get the
impression that you haven't had a lot of
direct experience both coaching and
interacting with so the INR my wife is a
world champion figure champion and
Brazilian champion South American
champion so you know I live somebody
that that trans as well so we talked a
little bit about gender differences or
lack of differences in terms of training
protocol here's a question from I really
prefer personal names but this is from a
Facebook page I guess our perfect body
quest okay I find that tells you but in
any case the question is please ask them
about the differences in training and
nutrition for enhanced versus natural
lifters and okay and we can define some
terms here so and I'd like to actually
clarify something because it's a it's
it's a just a personal note and so the
first is enhanced it can go by a number
of different terms could be using gear
could be using anabolics could be using
peds there are many different ways to
phrase it but also this is just a
something that drives me nuts so I'm
going to point it out for people if you
if you look at my Wikipedia page right
now there is a at least there has been a
line that says something along lines if
Tim Ferris has admitted to using like
susta non 250 HGH etc after surgery and
that drives me nuts because it's what
they would call on Wikipedia weasel word
I wrote an entire chapter in my second
book about the sort of benefits and
risks of a very
methodical anabolic you say after
reconstructive surgery which I used
after my shoulder was reconstructed so
that's something I just want to clear
the air on I didn't admit it it makes it
sound very shifty wrote an entire
chapter on it folks so so that all
having been said what are your thoughts
on training and nutrition differences
for enhanced versus natural lifters well
the thing with anabolic sand
I mean how they work is they enhance
your body's ability to recover them the
stress at some point your body is not
going to be able to recover from you now
especially putting on it and then you're
going to reach a plateau so athletes use
mainly under bullets they're always
which is derivative is testosterone now
hormone and also to some degree growth
hormone and to recover and repair from
the workouts so if somebody is using
enhancement the Diabolique sterile is
called enhancement for argument's sake
then when someone's using enhancement
they're going to be able to recover more
efficiently when somebody is not and
they're going to be able to they're
going to take things to a higher plateau
before again there's less or not so if
you're not using anabolic you're not
going to be able to train like a lot of
the guys you read about in the magazines
they might be trained five or six days a
week and two hours a day it's not
something I recommend but you know some
devise do some professionals do train
that much and if you try to do that
without enhancing your hormone level you
know you're going to get over trained
very quickly and you're not going to get
the results you're looking for
so I mean whether you use an anabolic or
not the process is this you go in the
gym and you put stress on the muscles
and and then they have to recover
if after they've recovered and there was
sufficient stress then they
overcompensate so your needs are now
lost time for that to happen so I use
this analogy at seminars sometimes very
very simple analogy but it gets the
point across if I was to take a piece of
sandpaper and rub it across the palm of
my hand and so let's kind of bleed in a
bit of damage by was to leave that for a
few days it would heal up and the skin
would be you know marginally stronger
and thick and it was before because he
wants to protect yourself from that
stress and that's basically you know
what happens with muscle growth so let's
say we take their situation again I get
the sandpaper rub it across the palm of
my hands it's all red and bloody and you
know I leave it for a day or two it's
not quite healed yet it's still a bit
red and I go and do it again we're not
getting anywhere right I just got bloody
hands and so it's the same thing with
training in the gym you've got our ply
stress and then you've gotta recover if
you're using steroids you'll be able to
cover more quickly and train more
frequently so it's all about the
recovery whether you use it or not you
have to be aware of recovery so it's
going to enhance your ability to recover
from that stress and it's going to be
able to go further than if you had any
use of us you know very basically how
they work and they should also say
obviously I'm not a doctor don't play
one on the internet but there are there
are potential risks associated with use
and abuse of any of these things for
people listening and if you're two
months into your training protocol or a
year whatever you're not a professional
there are very few circumstances in
which I would recommend certainly any
Cavalier use but medical medically
supervised use of a lot of these
compounds so it's not something to be
taken lightly as a decision but it is a
reality of almost every competitive
sport that has endurance power output
oxygen carrying capacity as primary
determinants of placement and whether
it's cyclists or sprinters or otherwise
even in something like the biathlon
people are would potentially use
something like beta blockers to calm
their nerves they take more effective
shots after elevating their heart rate
so when we got a couple of things in
England at least when I was a kid they
used to call sports I don't know why
they call sports but we've got one
called darts where the guys throw the
darts in a board right and another one
snooker which is a bit like pool and you
know even these guys they're using beta
blockers and drinking beer to help calm
their nerves and enhance their game you
know if it's competitive people are
going to do whatever they can to get
edge and I don't recommend them to
anybody I don't tell people what they
should do and just kind of be frank
about my experiences and leave it to
other people but to be honest if I was
not a competitive bodybuilder I wouldn't
I don't see the point in using steroids
and perhaps open yourself up to
potential health risks which which you
know which are there over the last
period and then you have the other
subject of you know using it
therapeutically for older guys that
their testosterone levels declining and
this causes age-related illnesses and
diseases which can be stemmed by putting
your testosterone back to normal
hormone replacement so to speak or
recovering from surgery and other
applications so you know they have uses
outside of the sports yeah yeah there
are definitely gentlemen applications
even in wasting diseases where you have
say decrease t-cell count so a lot of
there are some hiv-positive patients who
will use oxandrolone and things of that
type so for folks interested I'd suggest
educating yourself and it's a
fascinating subject with there's some
documentaries out there I think it's
bigger faster stronger which was done by
Chris Bell that features his brother
Mark Bell
who has become a friend fascinating
documentary people can do more homework
on their own so that the next question
is from Mohammed some our goals are at
the peak of your career were there any
days you felt stuck when things weren't
moving what did you do then
you know that when you get to the level
of top competitive level mr. Olympia and
so on and the more developed again the
higher up you get the the actual changes
and the gains of very very small you
know if if you put a you know three or
four pounds of muscle on over a year
when you're a professional level would
be considered a pretty good gain so
things really do slow down and it's
you're not going to get the kind of
progress you've got when you you know
when you first started out so it's more
of a you kind of cycle the training you
know you're trained hard for five or six
weeks and then you back down a little
bit train lighter and you go out the
game so you're looking for small gains
over the course of the year at that
point so you're not getting the feedback
used to get where you know you're going
to gin and wow look at the progress I
made since last month or something it's
it's more or less like maintaining it
and trying to improve on certain areas
most things like that so Dorian one
question that I would love to ask that's
maybe related is if you look back at the
period of time between the end of your
competitive career and now what have
been one of your darkest periods or dark
period for you and how did you find your
way out of it what were the things that
helped ah dr. spirit had probably kind
of a couple of years the first couple
years after I retired you know was I was
I didn't know what was going on I was
waking up at night I couldn't sleep
feeling nervous and I was diagnosed with
clinical depression you know I just been
forced retired from this thing I've been
doing so long and and a lot of things
kind of came to the surface that maybe
because you've got such tunnel vision
while you're doing it I realized there
was problem
my marriage that maybe I hadn't really
looked at because you know you're just
in this tunnel and keep going keep going
so all these kind of thing you may be
swept under the carpet so to speak well
you know it'll start popping out and so
you know had been retired from this
thing I was doing which is you know
could be quite traumatic for people
retired from the professional in any
case my marriage was breaking up
somebody very close to me passed away so
all these things like you know perfect
storm of disgust all at the same time
for me to deal with and either the one
thing that kind of got me through it was
going to the gym although I didn't have
that goal of training for mr. Olympia
just go to the gym and train it was like
a form of meditation for me where I
would forget about the outside world and
problems and so on so even now I just
love to Train I'm not really I'm not
doing weight training as I used to now
but you know for whether I'm riding my
bike or swimming or doing yoga or you
know functional training whatever it is
I really love to exercise and I think
that you know that helped me get through
that period and it took quite a few
years for I started you know balancing
out and maybe you know and now it's 20
years since I was competing you know and
I think I feel like I'm in a you know
really good place now but that's a lot
of time Tony Harrison what helped you to
find meaning in the sense that I mean
was there just a day when you surprised
yourself and you're like oh the clouds
are not hanging over my head or did you
sit down in Journal or have a some type
of friend or mentor who helped you to
find a direction or a purpose after
being competitive or competitors I think
I think a lot of people kind of you know
and a lot of reading and stuff I did
it's kind of kind of go figure out for
yourself and at one point I you know say
hey
I've been doing this thing for 1215
years and having been able to do this
and do that so let me you know go out
and party and be crazy and go to
nightclubs and let me travel and go here
and the calling Safari and things I
couldn't do before so I started to
realize instead of like looking at what
you lost look at what you gained right
you know I couldn't imagine living that
lifestyle that I was living as a
professional bodybuilder now you know
it's it's it's just you know be way too
restrictive now I couldn't do it you
know so yeah it took me some time to
find balance but the benefits are I feel
much more free person now not you know I
don't have to eat six times a day I
don't have to you know the other Juna
this time or yeah you know I mean saying
some discipline on you know because
that's my nature but then I've had to
learn to sometimes not have discipline
no great nice to get balanced though
does make sense and you mention books
that look - I love to read I mean that's
always love to read nothing that was a
huge advantage for me when I did bodybow
I just consumed books on training and
nutrition and kind of worked it all out
for myself and that was half of the fun
of it you know now guys I've got
nutritionists and trainers and managers
and God knows what else for me the whole
this body Bonin was an individual
pursues an individual test of character
and everything was not a team seems for
you know are there any particular books
that you've read or gifted to other
people well I'm reading a lot of stuff
at the moment of read quite a lot of
books from from one guy on a spiritual
level which has helped me so I'll just
say his name is name's Eric tetanus ppim
if you guys want to check them out I
think is a great spiritual teacher and
techniques and meditation and things
like that I find
a moment so is there a book of his that
you would suggest people start with the
one to start with would probably
handbook of the Navigator or meditation
into eternity will probably be the best
one either of those two the meditation
book is more on you know teach you and
Eric Pepin is very much like Arthur
Jones or you know Bruce Lee I call and
Bruce Lee the spirituality because it's
it's kind of like spirituality / science
and our science and spirituality now
pretty much coming together to be the
same thing with in a quantum physics and
stuff like that so I find it stuff very
logical you know so anyway
people are interested in spiritual side
of life I recommend John with some of
this stuff so this is going to seem like
a left turn but I don't think it I don't
think it totally is
so you mentioned to our mutual friend
Brian once and I'm simplifying here but
freedom is not giving a [ __ ] and I maybe
I'm miss quoting you but I would love to
hear you elaborate on that and maybe you
can give context as well yeah I think I
was talking to myself at first
you know because
you know there's still that thing you're
mr. Olympia right six times mr. Olympia
legend in the sport so I guess you feel
like you have to maintain some kind of
image or or whatever it is you know and
I thought you know I'm am I doing this
now am I trying to maintain some kind of
you know am I doing this training
maintain this level of physique for
myself or am i doing it for you know for
other people or other outside forces and
so I think it was a question for myself
a person like do you are you going to
live your life or make decisions or in
any way be controlled by the opinions of
other people or what you perceive to be
the other thinners of other people which
might not even be there in any way in
any case in the end you got to live your
life the way that you think you should
live it at that time and not be
controlled and we all lie you know we
controlled all the time from the day we
born were controlled by ever by our
parents opinion by the school's opinion
by the government's opinion by the
media's opinion and so on and I want to
be free of that so basically the greater
suspect I'm going to do what I need to
do and taking care not to hurt anyone
else and that's it I don't really give a
[ __ ] what anyone else thinks about that
in the afraid you also say that and
there are few different metaphors but
that that life is like a movie and I
enjoyed hearing you talk about that I
don't know if you could maybe elaborate
on that as well because it seems like
it's pretty closely related you know we
can go into quantum physics and stuff on
this but I mean what quantum physicists
have discovered is
that the reality we live in is not what
we think it is and it's made of computer
code and it's kind of our thoughts
interact with this code so therefore
your thoughts can help create your
reality so you know here on the Truman
Show man what do you what do you want to
do you know what do you want to do what
do you want to play in this movie you
know create that that story with your
mind you know and take steps to to make
it happen and it can happen so that's
what I mean by being a movie or a video
game or something like that you know
being the director in your own movie
away you're in a holographic movie and
check it out you know there's there's a
lot of other subject matter that we
could discuss that would it would
definitely veer into that territory very
quickly at some point we could talk
about that or just swipe April's office
- I love this web people's appetite and
for people listening or wondering what
the hell I'm talking about you can also
look up Johns Hopkins and psychedelic
and research in my name and you'll
you'll see a number of things pop up but
the one will last questions just just
one or two more if you had a gigantic
billboard and you could get a message
out to millions of people what might you
put on that billboard
so anything come to mind we are along we
are one what I want we are one well I
think that's a real part of one thing
we're all connected
just just like cells in a human body
they're all separate cells but they make
up the body so a part of one thing right
we are one here I think that's a good
place to wrap up Dorian I thank you so
much for your time and I stop now man
it's been fun so you know they will on
the back people want it back again they
want to ask more stuff let me know what
it is and well okay that's good John and
I will let you know and I'm sure plenty
of questions where can people best find
you
lines say hello see what you're up to
learn more about the certification we
mentioned yes as well as various places
Instagram is the Dorian Yates Facebook
we've got DeWine Nutrition a dy
nutrition website and DUI hid website
civics such story nice nutrition during
a high intensity training you know in
various ways you can get in touch with
me
well once again this has been like I
feel like a conversation 20-plus years
in the making some really thrilled to be
able to connect via an awesome remember
that phone call the good trousers a long
time ago you've had a lot of phone calls
but the point being that you at the time
were I may be the equivalent of say
reaching out to Bruce Lee for me and
you're very gracious in that phone call
and that's stuck with me really stuck
with me that you that you made the time
even though it was a polite decline
you're very very gracious and sorry I'm
still I'm look what happened to the seed
and now here we are so so I want to
number one thank you for the time and
for everybody listening you can find
links to everything we've talked about
all the books the certifications the
websites where you can learn more about
durian is Instagram in the show notes
for this episode you can find the show
notes for this episode and every other
episode at tim dot log forward slash
podcast or just search tim ferriss show
and show notes and it'll pop right up
and that is all
so everyone listening I hope you enjoyed
this as much as I did and until next
time keep experimenting be safe and
question your assumptions hey guys this
is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday is that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and 500 Friday
is a very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or the
been pondering over the week that could
include favourite new albums that have
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
have somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour workweek com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you will get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
WordPress my go-to platform for blogging
writing online creating websites
everything I love WordPress to bits my
site every site just about that I have
is run on WordPress and the lead
developer of WordPress Matt Mullenweg
has appeared on this podcast many times
the very first episode in particular is
amazing the second I took a ton of those
on so you should check it out
but WordPress where do I even begin I
mean the New Yorker uses it jay-z
Beyonce they use it 5:38
TechCrunch Ted CNN time whether you are
looking to create a personal blog a
business site both neither something
else you'll make a huge impact when you
build your website on wordpress.com and
directly from some friends at Google I'm
not going to quote them by name but they
say that WordPress offers the best
out-of-the-box SEO the search engine
optimization imaginable so if you're on
WordPress you immediately have a leg up
on everybody else
on search engines and so forth in my
experience I'm no medical doctor of
search engine optimization but I will
say that I used WordPress for years and
fell in love with it to the extent that
I became very close friends with Matt
and then became an investor slash
advisor to automatic which runs
WordPress com that is how much I believe
in this and that's how a lot of my
a most successful products and
investments have come about because I'm
in love with X and then I seek out X
nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
WordPress and that includes everything
from the huge sites that I mentioned to
neighborhood sites and it is super easy
to get started there's no need to worry
about security or upgrades or hosting
they offer 24/7 support and handle all
of that which allows you to focus on
creating the highest quality content you
can with the least amount of friction I
don't have to worry about downtime I
don't have to worry about getting
emergency emails if I'm on vacation or
something like that and WordPress is my
go-to solution for all of this I trust
all of my most important text on the
Internet
to WordPress and they can't buy that
with a sponsorship they can't buy that
with anything I want uptime uptime
uptime and quality and that is what I
have selected after everything that I've
looked at so check it out go to
WordPress that's wor DPR ESS comm
WordPress comp or slash Tim to receive
15% off of your website today
that's wordpress.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by soothe
dot-com the world's largest on-demand
massage service what and let me tell you
I have a high bar for this stuff I have
body work done at least once a week
because I broken my body I have 30-plus
fractures and hundred plus MRIs I need
bodywork so I have a very very very high
bar for that soothe which I've tested I
tested my assistants tested my employees
tested delivers a hand-selected licensed
and experienced massage therapist to you
in the comfort of your own home hotel
our office in as little as an hour I've
tested them in San Francisco I've tested
them at Austin obsessed with them all
over the place and I have to say I was
really really amazed at the quality of
therapists and I do not accept
mediocrity at all in this area the
process is super simple
think of it as improver for massages
right you
choose the kind of massage you want say
Swedish or sports massage deep tissue
whatever then if you want even up for
couples massage I imagine that's an edge
case as the tech people say but whatever
you set the lengthier massage let's say
you want 60 minutes 90 minutes two hours
and let's be real if you want a proper
massage go for nine years and 20 minutes
for God's sake and you select the gender
of your therapist and then click you're
off to the races and they bring the
massage table sheets oil music so you
can unwind no matter where you are and I
have used this at Airbnb s hotels etc
citizens in 50 cities including most
major US cities as well as London Sydney
Melbourne Toronto and Vancouver so
number one download the app soothe soo
th e in the iOS App Store Google Play
Store and then use the tweak code let me
try that again
use the code tightens 20 TI ta n to zero
tighten 20 all caps to get $20 off of
your first massage that's a lot that's a
very good discount so you should use it
so again download the app soothe soo th
e and try out the code tighten 20 all
caps for $20 not percent $20 off first
massage and if you're anything like me I
have been paying and I've been enjoying
so give it a shot
try out soothe and your muscles nervous
system and sleep will thank you for it
what's the first kind of read with that
it was pretty good that's an odd thing
okay enjoy bye
[Applause]